[Music]
oh ho
happy Tuesday yes we still play destiny
here at GameSpot is week seven of the
destiny resets look there's another mic
but I'm the only one here today so just
me me and you guys I'll be monitoring
chat twitch YouTube games 5 if you guys
have questions obviously send those
around but yeah tomorrow is the prestige
raid we're not streaming that but we
will have the lobby tomorrow it's gonna
be a little later than normal it's gonna
be at 2 instead of 11 but yeah we got a
new nightfall this week it's Exodus
black again
my least favorite nightfall strike or
strike because the boss is just a piece
of doodoo got Time Warp with prism and
so yeah kind of just you know see how
that goes
it'll be a little rough but I think we
can get through it all so I'm gonna show
you guys something real quick in the
tower ever verse is cent selling
something new what's up pelipper what's
up anime cosplay fan to 470 little
Christ that's a really long name what's
up MC hitman 1 9 0 7 0 7 0 there's two
seven zeroes there
let me get a third in here
or try to get a third somehow sign
welcome back
I'm doing alright hopefully you're
having a good day
Tuesday's are usually a pretty good day
for me because we get to play some
destiny get to hang out with you guys
which is always great yeah
[Music]
well yeah with time warp you got to jump
through rings to gain time obviously
that's the one this week prism is based
off of elemental damage so you want to
try to make sure your team has different
elements I'm gonna try this whole wrist
winner is apparently really good for
this week's nightfall so you can try
doing that it should be decent well give
it a go and then we'll just use the raid
rocket as well
Adam is hates everything with the timer
and that makes sense
he also said he hates this nightfall in
particular I don't like this strike in
particular I think that the time
mechanic I think it's fun the time warp
rings is kind of a little weird only
because you can kind of both jump
through a ring at the same time see you
definitely want to try to kill
everything first and then do that jump
through the Rings as through as many
rings as possible I think you can
technically glitch this one like the
anomalies as well oh I have three bright
engrams to open those up for you guys oh
we got a we got an exotic sparrow that
doesn't probably have that yeah that's
garbage if you don't have the insta
spawn Sparrow oh we had another one
that's the best kind so this one is not
the instant spawn one nor is that one
and we got garbage which is fine Oh what
the hell she's not selling it she was
selling a sevens Engram last night which
had the gold ship in it and I don't know
if that was an error or what but that
was definitely there yesterday
the other cool thing is uh the hard
light she's selling hard light ornament
this one looks cool so we have a hard
light and you want to make your hard
light look really cool I'd say by that I
think when this shader looks like crazy
to dawn and dusk if it'll load
that looks pretty crazy I think we're
gonna have to buy some of this I don't
think I'll ever use it but like oh man
I'm a space hold on I feel like that
pink would be really annoying in PvP so
let's just blow up some mods cuz clearly
I have too many mods oh cool
so now oops that was four shaders I'm an
idiot it's too early I haven't had
enough coffee yet I have too many
shaders what do we when we blow up here
okay this has the least we got a third
further Steiff Waldo says Jam yeah we do
someone at work is about to join us Jam
I told him not to jump through the
timewarps until we killed everything at
least for the first section alright
let's buy some of this dawn and dusk
this is how you end up losing a lot of
your bright DOS
that's fine so now I got that weird ass
shader just cool you can always get
bright desk back from like I'm never
gonna use this I don't even care that
it's exotic alright we just got 400
right dust back totally great but yeah
alright let's go do this thing wait
actually is he on yet we need our third
and then we'll do this we're just doing
a normal nightfall if you guys end up
asking me are we doing prestige we are
not all sorry heard there's like a
glitch in the prestige one which I'm not
100% true sure because I haven't tested
it myself but that's just what I heard
also if you guys were lucky enough last
week to buy the that one weird emote you
could glitch through walls with it
apparently no one did trials for the
clan last week yeah because their iron
banner was happening Bob obviously and
the other thing is that
there's not really a reason like you hit
305 and it's like well what do we do now
like there's no reason to like farm
powerful gear maybe you're short exotics
so you're farming you're chasing exotics
I feel like I have every exotic weapon I
definitely don't have every piece of
exotic armor and I think I have an
exotic Engram so we'll pop that later
it's at 300 which is nice I need to buy
more Maps I didn't even do look at how
lazy I was I didn't even do my neces
treasure maps last week so what's up bro
Kenji welcome back good to see a
familiar face
also CJ Fant I think a host on was
asking me about destiny on PC we'll
probably we have a launch livestream
chasidy will be running that and I
believe we'll have a special guest for
that and I'm not sure myself or anyone's
doing the livestream earlier than that
because I think it is dropping early
again kind of in Australia or New
Zealand time I only played IB last week
for the most part I did one raid but
yeah I did a lot of IB last week
it took me 49 packages effing packages
to get a full set of armor on my Titan
feels terrible it's solar guys not that
you can hear me because it's probably
it's now Boyd
yeah please shoot that guy he was
blowing on my pipe
all right guys okay sorry and taking
this plate
oh my goodness
Pike City look at look at where that
freakin pike gonna go
yeah it makes a lot of sense destiny am
i right or am i right but yeah this is
one of my least favorite night while our
strikes as mentioned earlier well we'll
get through it as we do every week I do
appreciate you guys all tuning in of
course means the world to me to be able
to play destiny too and hang out with
you guys it is a pleasure
of course what no is it all the way like
up there that's weird
yeah I just don't really see a reason to
do trials I don't personally care to go
to lighthouse I guess obviously it's
kind of a motivating factor I'd and I oh
we missed one all the way at the
beginning wrecked right diets a pipe I
guess I'll go revive him amateur move by
us good he died to this guy this one
vandal
oh you respond no probably jump through
these hoops Jim comebacks let's just
jump through these call it a day
Aaron if you can hear me on the stream
delay which will be like a hot second
actually they're both by on stream delay
we're gonna go jump through these hoops
together hopefully crap it's in the back
and I died yes I know you died what's up
Sepp septic I 5,000 oh dude there's so
many anomaly still what the hell all
right all right damn you jump then I'll
jump go alright whatever help I jump
when I don't
come on come on I hope you're here oh
crap
no let me jump through two
I get up there there's totally one up
there
no I'll grab this one see there's a lot
of rings though
oh there's one all the way back there
rings are destabilizing that's not good
all this time Aaron's just been in front
rings up collapse that's fine whatever
probably I did a better job but it is
what it is some more pulses oh wait
there's rings over here too all right
maybe there's just rings in the front
okay so we can kill this stuff and then
do the Rings
it is currently solar I could get over
there two rockets on this
it's Ark that guys fall it looks like it
all right
there's there's at least one ring there
I don't know why it's just by itself I
guess I'll just go grab I hope you have
fun with PC CJ I just don't have it in
me to like do it all over again
to be honest otherwise I would
potentially pay for PC but feel like I'm
missing audio right now
all right here we go I am totally yeah
oh look at that drop and you dropped
heavy yeah I could never sit oh the
Rings are destabilizing I don't even
know if there is more than one back
there because I only jump through one
just weird
unless I wreck us and there was more in
here I feel bad
our
oh so the cool thing about this is that
the electric shock stuff that's on the
floor here
causes the wrist runner to actually
count nesting so
you could essentially keep shooting with
him like tickling him though it's really
good for the shanks though solar now
that's a full energy to devour
and play too much a void caller used to
be my favorite class in one
mr. owner you're so unstable why
sprocket
oh no he's too close
rip Eric what gun would you recommend
the most repeat I've been waiting
patiently for PC release I need guidance
skate lock is decent when you first
start another pretty good one is your
definitely if you get a Uriel's gift
you're gonna want to keep that guy oh
please don't explode this summer thank
you good job boys you definitely want
your girl's gift is definitely ope
why does is really good so those are
some suggestions for PvP
real journey
we backing up okay risk runner is not
the business right now even though I
said it was like that
heavy
barrier down Oh God good luck everybody
oh that's a Kate six chest sorry
weird I thought I had the Devourer thing
to get life back what I don't know if I
do or not
oh please don't tell me we missed one I
don't think we did IV pulse is pretty
good too but a nightshade is probably
pretty close
IV pulse shoots faster than nightshade
so there's that what could a glitch it
to get more time but there's by time
thing is that that one dark room I guess
or hope we missed the whole set of rings
and we are in some trouble
it's fairly solar
I do walk
pick away with this slow pipe got his
leg
dude I don't remember these Pike's being
in the bank it's doing some work it's
doing so much work that it fell over on
its side
oh nice Boyd rocket there Oh arc yeah
now I'm gonna do some damage right here
oh they forced you out of the pipe and
ride that inside I guess all right we
have five minutes
first not great but there should
hopefully be time warps in here let's
just kill everything and hope that
there's time working on I think I saw
some light they're not it's gonna be a
little bit messy Solar careful of that
so that would be my PvP advice person
that ass Lionel the hint if you like
hand cannons I'm sorry to say that just
they're just not good enough right now
okay there's a time warp that one's
frickin weird though like upside down we
all jumping through that one together we
should wait where are the other ones try
to figure out where the hell the other
ones are without wasting too much time I
don't really see any other ones which is
a problem uh y'all need to get back here
I guess
alright damn 3 2 1 jump
I honestly don't see any more rings oh
they're all above us holy crap
no I just failed
I just died no I didn't dude there's
hella rings they're all above jump up
I hate while I jump so much
okay I'm failing us real bad right now
they're all above nope jump through that
wasn't Aaron yes
I think all the rings are gone now yep
okay well now you guys know that there's
hella rings in this room and we now have
four minutes to do this well that
couldn't have gone any worse then it
just did we now have four minutes for
the boss which is fun it is what it is
I was a Titan I would have made at least
three more circles I always big block
here
where are you I don't think we're alone
no [ __ ]
dirt behind you it's solar you should
have probably saved that smash but okay
this is probably gonna be why Peru might
guess we'll see where this big dude I oh
I miss my Nova to be sick sick Dodge bro
so her x equals arch match yeah well I
just whipped my Nova so what can i
really say
and rip down
they're really gonna hurt solar
[Music]
whereas do that
game please spawn the boss I miss mine
after shooting this stuff problem
oh I see you
nope
team synergy cannot attend well it's
kind of hard there they're watching on
Adelaide so it's like I can't expect
them to know the bosses oh this is
getting real hairy probably a wipe skis
all right
all right we try again
because it's pretty sure this is there's
no way we just need to do a better job
of getting the rings in that one room
that none of us knew what we were doing
what the [ __ ] are you doing that's a
good question
it's called we ran out of time we need
to jump through more circles of which we
didn't do so we're gonna try again here
we go it's pretty straightforward it's
what happens on night falls you got to
figure out the thing
what's up midnight chrome
so we'll try again I mean technically we
could have like the boss on this strike
is just stupid wants to be real like
every other boss in a strike you could
just like do you X amount of damage
without him running away but this boss
literally runs away like every I don't
know 10% 15% so not only does this boss
suck but I'm not a huge fan of the the
ring mechanic in that last room but also
we didn't technically we could
technically glitch back and do these
front rings again but we didn't do that
I don't feel like we need to there's
more about getting the rings in that one
room that like we probably only got to
of like 10 just seemed like there was a
lot they're not saying that I'm gonna do
any better this time but at least I have
an idea that they're above us and yeah
Aaron messaged me saying yeah you want
to jump up and through those rings
I don't know this freaking general
disappea in the butt because that last
boss is or the boss and all the stuff
that spawns is like there's no pretty
much like I wouldn't say there's no
cover but there's very little cover
everything up to that was good do we
miss one in the beginning I really hope
there's one in there are ways that the
ring okay he's got all the pulses yeah
so the other strategy is you just clear
you have as many people jump through the
hoops as possible which will try to
attempt this time
but really the the struggles there was
from God Aaron died thanks for pushing
again I'm guessing he's one to revive
them yeah make sure you get the rings in
that last room cuz it's probably need
like a good let's not do that I'm gonna
JM when you're when you can hear this
I'm gonna head back to the Rings
technically missing a pulse to go all
the way back I think so the other
interesting thing is like that one ring
then spawns other rings so I must have
triggered something else in that second
set of rings that I didn't see that we
might that we missed you so there's
three sets of rings at least so we are
making it kind of harder on ourselves so
I'm gonna wait for them here what God am
I using asked yoga D boy I'm using night
midd nameless midnight which is like a
really good scout risk runner which has
been okay I thought it was gonna be
better it it kind of can be especially
with the all the arc damage that's
coming in like consume your grenade
that's not what I want do i yeah I guess
it is alright anyways alright three two
one go
I'm scrubbing it up go go go go go go go
I should technically be waiting for them
to go through these but
I think we're good yep cool all right
that's cool we got 15 minutes we're back
to where we're at there's one more ring
over here that probably triggers another
set because it's right there so probably
clear out the ads and then jump through
that and I figure out where the ring
spawn because I do not see it there's a
visible dude don't jump through that
ring yet if you can hear me all right
well we did it anyways there's more
rings that's fine that are like totally
on the opposite side of the map this is
why in a perfect world you're on comms
with who you're playing with so that you
can actually get through all these rings
because what's happening is the trigger
one and then the rest spawn a bunch over
here I don't even know how you get
through those come on
I got through one more at least but this
is why you want to try to kill
everything before you jump through the
rings obviously so that you can jump
through them safely and so that your
teammates can get through as many as
possible all right my grenade right into
Aarons back
so like the reason restaurateurs get it
I think every time you get a kill the
reloads also it does kind of like our
conductor thing
alright well we might as well go because
there's no rings left storm transfer
warlock what's up warlocks I don't
actually normally main a warlock but I'm
glad the warlock people are in chat
warlocks my second favorite character
Titans my number one my number one BAE
it is
well we're definitely have way more time
than we did last time like quite good
couple of mins so that's definitely
gonna help that last part we just gotta
be ready to spin out and jump at the
last part
pindy now it's art okay kind of good and
bad
this wedding on the floor looks like
some kind of art conductor
that's funny please I like art
conduction away now showing it's worth
as mentioned before especially with dark
floors a thing not solar though
should've devoured their mechanics or
solar right now there's like
all right quick
I got a solar rocket
those girls
it did not
I know it's the solar office but
whatever still going to do damage
where is his body
[Music]
barrier is down some Sparrow racers we
are I like Titan as a flashpoint
I wish Titan was bigger death sauce it
could it could be better at her -95
saying finally hit 301 grats why do you
do the rings ask unnamed person because
this week's nightfall is to gain time we
have to go through rings it's the time
warp mechanic the other mechanic is
prism which is element the ship is full
damage does more damage depending on the
polarization that it says there so solar
give you our solar weapons it'll do more
damage and its arc our collectors do
more same with abilities etc and then if
it's void etc and void I'm gonna use
this heavy pike again because it seemed
to do some work last time but I think
really what was happening is my boys
were using their rockets actually no it
doesn't quite a bit of damage
now we're all using them now kind of get
them bad depending on you look it is
because it's not Ark right now those
things are actually doing academic-based
avoid
break it though
with our analysis guys gonna melt my
bike would stay afloat
shoot the orange thing here and you can
do it good job good job everybody we did
it
all right this going in this room we
have ten minutes last time we had five I
feel pretty good about it next week PC
finally that's correct
eighty spore jester X will have a launch
livestream for that oh yeah stay tuned
for that fun stuff
it's gonna be good here we go all right
let's not jump through that ring until
we're ready I don't know I'm thinking we
should totally spread out with that the
ring show
I'm not jumping through that ring yet
clear out the ads
like this no 80s Scout action
you there stop that that it alright
let's go back let's go back and jump
through this thingy and then we should
position ourselves in different spots
hopefully to get as many rings as
possible I know a bunch like Swan over
there maybe I should just start it and
then you guys can jump through I was
able to complete this in five yeah you
need about five minutes with boss that
sounds about right
alright here we go good luck everybody
alright the Rings are up above there
Oh
I'm not really sure how you get more of
those though we're so freaking high
no I I refused I got one more
that was jam oh there you go get through
him
no he's so close all right just pull us
forward I mean either way we have 10
minutes which is like a lot of time too
I only got a couple of those rings but
as you can see guys as long as you do
the front rings pretty well just
coordinate you should be good also
remember you can jump have multiple
people jump through rings so it's
another thing we can do
wow I died says J here we go we can't do
it in nine minutes I don't know what to
say that'd be actually quite awful
that's it I'm counting like deaths do
feel pretty good about it maybe I won't
with my Nova this time
chaton casting this game got boring
after we three can only do the same sort
of striking ray flash point three this
week yeah I can kind of see it that way
I'm still enjoying it it is a little bit
I have less incentive now because I'm
kind of almost maxed to everything
except my hunter
mark
solar
backed off
so Foley
any plans assuming the PC version asked
gams that have a [ __ ] buck draw sorry
yes we will have a launch dream chasidy
will be joined by a special guest for
that one we may or may not do like a
launch like a like an earlier launch
team we'll see that's a good Nova to
finally hit my Nova which is good
No
damnit
that's what
apparently
are you shot by too much stuff to out
you'll lose everything
our ads six minutes he's like at half
life no problem
the only thing that's mildly annoying is
it will spawn you into like heart damage
so it's like he's got to careful
[Music]
like ow Aaron switched from he's just
switching guns while he's like
have no void boys my marriages
this mr. bossman of Arc
bosses right here
[Music]
oh he punted me off to me a mistake it's
okay he's so close that they're so close
he's so close to dying it like doesn't
matter I mean as long as it doesn't
disappear again he might that's the one
part that sucks about being up top is if
he hits you and you jump sometimes it
unless I just failed jumped which is
possible I might have just jumped off
dumb dumb one mistakes were made
yes definitely over there
there you go that's what you gotta do
just got a flip the table just make sure
you have like seven five to seven
minutes and you'll be fine
cool thanks to everybody
is he in colorblind mode yes I just find
that the colors pop a little bit more
it's just me personally I'm not actually
colorblind oh yeah that's right risk
we're on our guys risk runner there you
go
hundred twenty eight kills boom yeah so
we'll do we'll do some think we'll do
some flashpoint now that we've conquered
that which is the nightfall
so again just try to coordinate with
your team get through the ring let's get
as many rings as possible that last room
was still weird I'm sure there's a
better way to get all the Rings now do
the broken prestige I'll pass neuroses
I've seen that it's glitchy and I don't
even want to bother considering how much
we struggled with just that she's gonna
do some good ol casual you know stuff
here so as this little is the Luke Rhine
in this still okay for finishing a
nightfall I mean you're gonna want to
you're gonna want to do the night Paula
gesture each week if you're looking on
playing PC because you're gonna get a
high and drop from the nightfall as well
as getting two drops from Zavala one
that's almost usually an exotic but not
always but what I would say is if you're
starting on PC for all the people that
are starting PC if you're trying to mid
max what you want to do is not do your
nightfall till the end of the week
before reset because you want to get as
high up as you can before doing some of
those later milestone activities do not
do not anyone that's playing on PC turn
in your
milestones until the end of the week
before reset until you can't get any
higher light because you're just gonna
screw yourself otherwise we're okay what
the hell get up there I was up there
whoops
Oh Bob there's like some weird glitchy
thing where you can't get past something
I think tokens is kind of not a great
systems 84 gesture I feel like it's it
was fine for the faction wars because
you could endlessly farm those tokens
but for something like iron banner I
think that it was a mistake for them
just to do tokens and to go away from
the old system which is a progression
based system that did ultimately give
you Ingram's
but you also were able to just outright
buy pieces of armor and weapons from
that specific IB they wouldn't sell you
everything so it's like there are two
sets of gloves with random perks which
they don't have anymore so they could
sell a helm in a glove and then like two
of the weapons but then you could just
randomly get the rest I think would have
been fine some people including myself
had really bad luck in terms of getting
armor sets from iron banner
it took me 49 packages I've read
something on reddit where like one guy
had open 27 packages and never got a
piece of armor so those are problems
septic I 5,000 the best and fastest way
to get exotics is probably do these
public events of which there are heroic
public events in which case you just
have a higher chance to get exotics
another pro tip is if you guys have
bright dust from getting bright engrams
you definitely want to use a fireteam
medallion with the people you're playing
with because that also helps increase
your chance for gear drive Duke says
there is a fix for the prestige
nightfall bug it's on youtube I saw that
one of the fixes was to use the broken
ass emote that they had that lets you
glitch through walls to fix it and I
don't know if that's the actual fix but
I'll have to check that out
the way that those rings are positioned
how the hell it does Bungie expect you
to get them so dumb lol good luck
against the boss dude ah I think that
the way Bungie sees it is either one a
bunch of destiny people that make
youtube videos or streamers will show
people what they need to do to get to
those rings or you're gonna just end up
doing what we did which is we didn't
really know exactly we kind of went in
blind and so in that case you're just
like figuring out where the ring
positions are and you end up doing it
twice I mean there's some point in that
I can understand why people might be
frustrated by that but hey it's a it's
of what we had to do week one you know
what I mean so unless you're watching a
YouTube video you wouldn't have known
otherwise so to trigger this heroic
public event for the people that don't
know because there's gonna be some
people that clearly are gonna be playing
on PC what we need to do is unlock all
of the turrets that are over there the
turrets will be unlocked once this guy
drops some like balls essentially once
he goes down there are three balls you
need to do it twice
obviously as to then get three more
balls so mocking you don't want to kill
the Walker though until you get these
turrets out if you don't then you'll
just get a normal event which is fine
too but haruka events I believe give
more it's potentially it's got to get
more experience and it definitely gives
a better chance at more drops you can
get up to like four drops whereas like a
normal version might only give you like
two but just know that you don't always
get four is just a chance to get four
on a scale of one to ten how would you
rate your firepower in destiny - pretty
high
we need to unlock that last part I have
pretty much like everything in the game
I think that you can get maybe - and
gunsmith stuff and some
so if you triggered the heroic event
you'll get that notification that hey
you're in a hurry but we've been also a
second Walker will drop now there's more
than one public events so just be
mindful of that because they each have
their own triggers to turn your hair oh
so that's just this one somewhere doable
solo they're kind of hard solo obviously
you want to try to get a fireteam if
possible it'll make things a lot easier
for you the only one good thing about
Titan as a flashpoint CAAM is that it
takes a lot less of these public events
to actually level it to 100% takes like
three I think so we did it on heroic and
I think Jim has a token we'll see how
well this chest goes we only got two
things so it makes me look like a liar
Thank You destiny game the thing that
sucks though is I think they kind of
stealth nerfed the public events a
little bit like they don't spawn as fast
as they used to so unfortunately there's
no public event for us to do right now
so the only other thing we can do is uh
like patrol stuff to bump up the weekly
events but yeah you only need to hold
the Scorch cannon for five seconds yeah
I held it longer there I was like Getti
oh sorry Goldie's gaming I held it
longer there because the Walker had not
spawned totally in yet so even if I let
go of the trigger there it would have
netted me like nothing ultimately
yeah I do yeah he's just running in a
circle what the hell is when you just
need a sword
hoping your engrams I'll open them at
the end of the stream a name that I
cannot read no fortunately sorry oh wow
Philip saying if you complete a public
event and don't get the chest and walk
to another public event on the same
planet your rewards will stack and you
can stack up to three public events
that's good
gamespot next time you go live do the
Ray with some people you don't know
that's pretty tough to be honest and
it's not like I have a group that can
Sherpa I could potentially have like a
group of five and then Sherpa one but
chirping two's kind of hard and it's not
like I do it a lot and so it's I don't
know I tried helping my old some of my
old co-workers for those of you that
know Josh Shaw found mechanists those
fellows and we got to the gauntlet and
we came close to beating the gauntlet
but uh I think fatigue set in and then
we ultimately kind of wiped that day but
we could have killed three bosses
potentially so it was kind of doable
considering some of them were like only
272 like two like low 270 pretty
impressive actually
Goldie's gaming we are on a ps4 I play
pious boy mainly yeah magic eh if you're
not into the game sorry that you find
destiny boring books there are people
that enjoy this game myself included I
will be honest though like as of late
because of the fact that there's less
and less to do and because 305 is a hard
cap I find it less rewarding to come
back because there isn't anything to
grind for and the old destiny one of the
things that you would grind for even if
your max power level was just insane
god-tier rolls of weapons but they've at
least in the current game do not have
that so once you kind of get everything
you just kind of have everything
I love playing ring-around-the-rosie
with captains
oh that is unfortunate
Goldie's gaming saying light isn't
getting updated in this update I think I
wouldn't be shocked if you're right
Goldie from what I can tell unless we're
mistaken I feel like even the prestige
raid is just for aesthetics and I'm not
even sure if we're gonna get any light
boosts from that which kind of makes me
sad because it's like what's the point
of doing a hard mode raid just to get
like gold tier armor or a gold version
of their current radar well I don't I
mean outside of like I guess the
prestige of it and people knowing that
you did it like what do you really get
you get an aura - I guess Legend of a
curious I think has potentially an
ornament that you could earn by
finishing for seed raid but it's like
what are you gonna do are you guys
planning on doing guided Games event for
newer players potentially but the sad
part is everything I've heard so far
about guided games and people's
experiences has not been good so I think
it's a system that you know bungees
obviously gonna continue to work on and
sort out and try to polish because its
current system is not super hot because
those people have to be receptive and
they definitely need to listen and I
don't feel like everyone listens but you
never know I'm sure there's there's good
stories too and I just have heard of
like the bad ones you know yeah we're
gonna do it once just to say that we did
it or try to do it once to say that we
did it but outside of that if it's just
gold armor I don't think even my group
is gonna do it
well that's there's a difference 84
gesture with he's basically saying that
competitive overwatch gold weapons
that's about it bragging rights but this
is this game if you've ever played you
know any raid in destiny one the hard
mode of those raids always had something
different other than armor it was like
there was more light in
you know the taking King Juan as well as
some weapons you couldn't get I think
our wait maybe you could get the weapons
the same weapons but they're a different
color
obviously like we weren't doing it for
the different color it was that there
was a light boost right so you went from
I don't know 305 310 to 320 I think was
the max I'm taking King so there was a
reason to raid outside of just the
aesthetics of the weapons like sure it
was cool to have like the black version
of a smite of Moraine which was like a
pulse rifle in that raid but you know
the main reason was that oh hey like
cool I can um I can get up to 320 and I
was chasing 320 like now it's like okay
is the prestige mode just it's a
prestige mode just gold armor and that's
it and no light boost because if that's
the case like what's the point
you know I should cry stop hitting his
underbelly and they actually did like
I don't know it's also weird to just
think that like I don't know I feel like
there's some things that they learned in
d1 that they didn't pour it over to meet
you and I find it weird that they didn't
yeah definitely one of these
I definitely need one
no angle on that guy you guys take care
of here
I don't know I kind of wished like there
would be this evolution where they could
try this Wow World of Warcraft thing
which is they allow just casual players
to kind of team up and do the raid but
there's like an easier version of that
rate so then that gear is then capped to
a certain power level as to then not
overly reward people for doing the raid
but it gives them the experience of
doing the raid and that's where you do
the differentiation of like hey this guy
has did the the simple the simple
version of the raid so he's wearing the
brown coloured tier of this although
that's harder because of uh I guess
shaders but there was a way to
differentiate when someone did normal
and hard and they always had a reason to
do the hard other than just getting the
same gear or whatever there was always
like more light or whatever so there's
like I don't think Bungie is going to
change the game much until the first DLC
yeah I mean they're David making some
small subtle changes but yeah I'm not I
wouldn't be shocked if there isn't like
big changes until then I'm hoping that
come next iron banner they learned their
lesson from this one though in - oh man
I killer saying sex that we have nothing
to grind for until the DLC comes out
which is most likely increased power
level yeah it's uh I really hope that we
have a raid though and that DLC that
trials of Osiris based DLC that would be
obviously really cool to maybe have one
in mercury I think the social space is
probably gonna be light house so if
you've never been to the light house
you'll get to see it experience it for
the first time which is good
but yeah
you should have stacked your Chester
words
yeah that's fine I again fill up at this
point I don't even need to mid max or
anything anymore I mean we could have
tested it for theory I suppose I mean I
wish I had something to kind of grind
for like I don't mind the grind if it's
like I don't know I kind of liked
chasing the perfect weapons to be honest
I mean it I was frustrated by it but at
the same time when you actually did get
it like a god role as Luna or God roll
clever dragon or I don't know when you
got hung jury hung jury was like so good
those were that was what kind of was
driving people to keep playing to like
leveling their factions and things like
that I mean it's hard though because you
know Bungie is obviously trying to get a
new demographic as well into this you
know starting fresh at destiny - trying
to introduce more new players to the
game which they have for sure and they
will with PC and in doing so I feel like
the game got a little bit more casual
which I'm not
so what can I say I feel like they give
you too many too much like you could not
play the game and if that your clan does
what they're supposed to do you'll get
four powerful engrams every week so if
you just join a good clan you get four
powerful engrams a week you do all your
milestones that's like another five or
six you're like sitting pretty right so
this game needs more of a Diablo 3
aventure mode incorporating into it or
our public events already like that um
I'd rather have something more like d3
adventure mode that'd be cool I like
that public events are better a lot
better than the destiny one public
events I'll give them that
they're just Oh I mean I've done them so
much now that they're not as as fun as
they were in the beginning but I mean I
just like that there's variety between
the events and that there's a heroic
version of the events and that was cool
as a free triple zero cake I still have
not done the raid I never have enough
people and guy to games doesn't work
yeah I got a games is tough right now
like it doesn't work the way they want
it to and I don't know I think your bet
your better bet
to be honest free zero zero cake is to
try using like sites like destiny LMG
net or even the Bungie lfg and seeing if
you can partner up there cuz I think
that would be faster than guided games
to be honest if people are still using
that they used to use that in destiny
one and it was actually a pretty decent
system I for the most part got lucky and
I never really had any bad like teams
that were like you know aggressive with
you or putting you down or anything like
that they were generally pretty nice
folks trying to teach players you know
what to do in the raid you know what or
in certain events which rifle is that
this is the nameless midnight it's
probably one of the best PvE Scout
rifles the other really good PvE scout
rifle that I don't have on me is
Manong on or so what's called a good
rocket launcher is the raid one as well
as the vanguard one which is called
curtain call
masta 5 t saying LF G is good J M 76
also saying L of G is good
what about seasons are leagues from path
of Exile rolling new character or
rebirth one if the grind wasn't so long
seasons would make sense they do have
seasons in this I don't exactly know how
that all pans out we'll have to see
because our clan has a season and our
clans already max-level for season one
don't loose
my key linger it's not there how are we
getting me shredded we might not be able
to trigger her own
I'll shoot the crystals
so every time it's on a planet specific
planning for the milestone they always
generally spawn like you like an extra
ad kind of thing so like this epistle
the other big ass tonight that came out
as a product of Jesus is no life showing
me or p.m. Riggs is also very Opie as
you can see that is a hunter exotic he
basically keeps refilling his like super
based on how much stuff he kills I'll
show you guys a little bit it was
probably laggy of [ __ ] on the street it
also looks really cool I don't actually
have these boots yet on 100 so these
guys so
there it basically makes your your
tether come up like crazy fast
that's weird usually four is enough for
the milestone and we're 7% short which
is pretty butts so we're heading back to
this other spot so our claim that guided
to deaf people through the raid and it
was great accomplishments that's pretty
cool
that you were able to do that because
the interesting thing is we were talking
about how there's these really cool like
audio music cues to kind of tell you and
point you in the right direction so it's
pretty crazy that you're able to kind of
guide to deaf people do it your raid
because I don't know how you visually
tell them like you know hey let's go
kill a dog or something I guess you just
have to type a lot of that stuff out
the gauntlet it was the hard part yeah
that's what I would do there is if I'm
running the gauntlet and you have two
deaf people I'd probably have to teach
deaf people be the ones that are the
primary runners making the call-outs
because then at least they're just
calling out and they don't have to
really like listen for anything at that
point
is there pvp and PVE specific loot yes
there are some weapons that are crucible
kind of specific and then there are some
that are PvE specific same with armor
armor is more aesthetics and some of the
stats but yeah they can't hear and talk
Oh interesting how would you how would
you do the gauntlet then at that point
you would have to have the two people
that are shooting the things shoot both
of their targets because how would they
know to shoot top middle bottom at that
point
what's up toast man I can't wait for you
to put this into our rapper article
I'm guessing is it there
yeah wrists burner was pretty good
gamespot to you sometimes do crucible
yes sometimes we do I just did a lot
because of iron manner that was that was
a stretch we could play acoustic will
match after this and call it a stream
just do one crucible match so you can
check that out I'm not the greatest song
warlock but that's fine I honestly can't
tell the difference between this and
destiny one visually it looks better
that's for sure
some of the mechanics are the same
obviously I mean they spent three years
refining a game if you expected it to be
like vastly different I think that would
be kind of like crazy to think I guess
because why would you spend that long
refining and making a game better
so then have it be like that different
if you think about Diablo 2 and one
granted that like time frame was a
bigger there's a bigger gap there
obviously but gallo 3 is basically
Diablo 2 just with updated visuals right
and slightly different game gameplay in
the sense that you're locked to less
skills
a Kurd reading destiny 1.5 yeah I mean
yeah sort of
hey it's better than 1.5 though it's
like a 1.75 there's definitely some good
upgrades in here
but yeah can you rate with different
people for the next shame live the thing
is the rate takes a long time especially
if people haven't done it so like I only
have about 90 or so minutes to live
stream every day so it would be very
hard for us to get through the raid so
unfortunately you know if you're coming
from console to PC I think it'll feel
more like a sequel yeah because you
probably didn't really played d1 alright
I'll give you that alright that's good
at least you found a mutual agreement
yeah I didn't fill on stay - you didn't
you went for a moment for five - 1.75
that's solid upgrade unfortunately
except a guy probably can't help guide
through the raid but uh we do have some
guides on gamespot.com if you're looking
for like general tips and strategies on
how to do it but a lot of it honestly
comes down to execution and your team's
performing those execution
well yeah I mean the time is gonna
matter for me because it's still work
obviously so it's harder for me to to
then be able to be like yeah well Sherpa
like some of the stream people through a
rage when I can't commit that much time
in a given day
at least not without a my boss
potentially getting no okay what are you
doing oh you know just chirping like I
don't know if you watch giant bomb.com
or if you know if Giant Bomb John bomb
is our sister site they did the raid
mostly blind with a group of six only
one person had ever done it and he
didn't pretty he didn't really give them
strats and I would say all in all the
raid for them which they live stream
combined took them I say like 20 plus
hours to do in one week like I don't
have that time to commit
what about an 8 a stream maybe but it's
like asking me to give up six hours of
like my Friday or Saturday personal time
maybe
you showing your own channel anymore a
spooky 7 yeah I do sometimes I did last
week for Ironman or anything I can't
remember that oh no I don't remember the
specific Dave a Fuji ISO screen
periodically 84 jeserac saying fov makes
a big deal for me yeah the fov slider on
destiny 2 on PC is like amazing
I think graphically it's gonna even look
better than what you see here it's gonna
be a weird adjustment if I did try to
play PC only in the sense that why I'm
so used to like the my muscle memory for
console that like it's hard to adjust
you see I guess
oh I think about it hey
I'll say those story interesting to is
women we're changing the first one yeah
the story nursing to is a lot better I
think that the for the most part - I
feel like the missions in DT story were
better - now I'm not a fan of doing it a
sect like a second or third time but the
first time it was very solid feel like
it's kind of long the second time around
but at least the second time around you
can kind of use your Sparrow you
transfer over your Sparrow or as you
couldn't do that in your first play -
because they want you to you know go
through the environment enjoy that yeah
we just finished flashpoint we'll go do
a PvP match and we'll call thanks a good
one
took us a couple of tries for the
nightfall but that was kind of expected
I feel like since we kind of went him
not kind of weed straight I went him
blind and did not know where the warp
rings were which are obviously key
I have a lot to do now I am generally
pretty busy on that the weekends now all
right I have none of my PvP weapons
prosecutor is pretty good but Oriels is
still better let me see if I can move it
over with my destiny app can at least go
main ingredient oops
main ingredient is a very good for that
for the person that asked me about PvP
weapons the main ingredients a strong
weapon it's a fusion rifle if you didn't
know there is a destiny phone app that
allows you to move gear around it's
pretty useful there's also something
called Ishtar I think someone made that
himself for phone as well and then on PC
there's a Chrome extension that I use
called destiny item manager which is
also a really good one
so
[Music]
this is like the meta materials gift
meta I'm gonna be that guy I just use
aerials that's fine
Midnight's okay for view P as well lark
do you not drunk asking Tay do you have
ex back to or sorry do you have any
expectations for the dlcs like a big
storyline new different weapons maybe
even another class I know that's a long
shot though I mean I really wanted
another subclass because to be honest we
really only got one new subclass and
even then it was like more like half
because dawn blade is just sunbreaker
the grenades are the same as sunbreaker
the melee is the same as sunbreaker the
only difference is the super so instead
of self res you get to fly around with
your sword which is cool and throw like
flaming sword projectiles defender
slightly different again because you get
Captain America you get to use your
shield that's cool I think that's more
different than what old defender Titan
was and then arks rider is basically
Blade Dancer with like longer reach so I
was really hoping that something like
cold heart would actually be like like
kind of like a Frost type of element but
it's arc and hoping that there was gonna
be like a like freeze cold element type
subclass but there isn't one I don't
expect there to be one of the DLC I
expect there to be new weapons and new
armor obviously if you ever play this
map and for his respite do not ever if
you have a and B do not ever grab C
because C is just so bad on this map and
it actually feels really bad hopes to
die like that but when you're playing as
as somebody that has C it is so hard to
break a and B if the people at a and B
aren't like greedy and they actually
just straight hold their points because
yeah it's just tag them there
I'm just gonna Yolo it
how long until they're 30 Ruby I don't
think they're like as procedurally I
know I don't know if they're actually
procedurally generated in warframe but I
don't think they're as random I mean
stuff does randomly occur from time to
time but we stopped them from getting
their heavy yeah no no I was trying to
stall them from getting the heavy but
they got anyways well yeah there's no
there's no real reason for me to even
cross over there other than try to deny
them of their heavy
what's up Dominic do you think they'll
rate rise the level cap to 25 like they
did the first one ah they might in the
DLC just to kind of like at you to do
more story but that's that's all I can
think of one's going to a think or not
they're like no damage and got a point
for that sick yeah see you like this is
a nightmare like what is what is C
supposed to do the best they can do is
try to go hard left here do that to get
to a or try to go hard right to get the
a but like if you're a coordinated team
like they're never there never breaking
this where's your power level I'm 305
good trade like the only way they're
breaking this is if the person on our
team decides to go over to see and like
try to like cap see that's when you get
ruined
you never that's why I said never cap
see and you're good like I know they
have to take a from you essentially
because B is not going to be enough and
that guy has rockets
take the take the kill for that so yeah
they're trying to finally take a we're
trying to slowly push to a but they'll
probably never get there
people just do their job you're called
so what does the max power to get to 305
from C could split two groups to attack
me yeah but if you're good with
call-outs these sight lines are so like
tight that it would be very hard for
them to get through as long as the the
one team is calling a proper look like
what it was I mean a super could break
it to if one guys like playing really
well but it's still gonna be really
tough will you ever play with your
followers uh yeah mari t kill we did
last week just to going to a I don't
think they can hear me though
I only took three shots to kill that guy
that's fine now that was a mistake
thought I was a Titan was gonna try to
put a barrier up but that didn't happen
so much so now they're gonna try to take
me maybe but even then guy said I had
just been on the other end of the
spectrum so it's really frustrating best
Titan filled for PvE I think Stryker
I think alpha Luke he's like really good
because double pulse grenade is just
really really strong in PvE it has like
a very big radius and it does a lot of
damage so definitely would say okay our
guy just cast it is super probably
jumped over here ready hey he's right
there
Oh Captain America please
so yeah definitely the double grenade
tighten with pulse good shots good shots
yeah it's double pulse is just Opie in
so many so many different ways see they
finally broke us but look at what the
score is like I wouldn't even bother
grabbing see right now
right there
[Music]
no his just lasted slightly longer I got
like a five kill with that damn it and I
lost my heavy that sucks
stuff Asian what's up yo yo yo
[Music]
shadow shotted I see like pulse grenades
like really good like challenge it's all
about team shouting - and PvP will be
honest yeah see are they supposed to do
use all the supers keep them off the
thing like easy just keep making a
call-out get to 100 goes bad well yeah
that should about do it
thank you - JM and our Aaron Sampson
which is blam bomb for hopping in and
doing the nightfall with me appreciate
that appreciate you all you guys tuning
in and spot live usually on Tuesdays
will do PvP or sorry not PvP will do
destiny - weekly resets sometimes we get
new games we'll probably playing some of
those a lot of big releases coming up
ahead so I'm sure you'll be seeing some
Assassin's Creed Mario Odyssey
Wolfenstein - there's a bunch of stuff
coming out so stay tuned for that
tomorrow lobby again is getting pushed
back to 2 p.m. Pacific which is in about
an hour and a half from now if you're in
a different time zone instead of 11 a.m.
as we've kind of got the studio locked
up for some other stuff but there won't
be any streams in at 11:00 but every
other day we're on at 11:00 a.m. Monday
to Friday so make sure you hit that
follow like subscribe button so you guys
get notifications of when we go live I'm
normally not by myself I normally have a
co-pilot with me but it's been a busy
week
you know sad face lone wolf in it for
destiny too but yeah other than that
I'll see you guys next time I hope you
have a happy Tuesday
warriors play tonight go warriors I know
people are gonna hate that's fine I'm
even wearing a draymond shirt which is
gonna even upset more people if you're
into basketball enjoy enjoy opening
night or just whether Houston but and
there's I think there's playoff baseball
so if you care about that cool but until
next time I'll see you guys later thank
you guys all for tuning in bye bye